another person who is currently being
canceled and his apologies are not going
to matter
is morgan wallen so morgan wallet is
this country star this massive country
star
he shared a video on wednesday in which
he apologized for being caught in a in a
drunken
uh on uh on tape being a drunk basically
and and yelling at one of his friends
the n-word now
was he actually using the n-word as a
way of denigrating black people or was
he using it the same way that rappers
use the n-word
i know that we're supposed to strip
intent in context from all of these
conversations
but um he was not actually calling a
black person the n-word because that is
just blatant racism
instead he was using it the same way
that rappers used the n-word
right he was just saying drunkenly to a
friend blah blah blah blah and word okay
that is not good i don't like the use of
the n-word period end of story
right i don't say it in my life i don't
like i won't
accept people in my life who say it to
me or or with me in
in my presence like that's not something
that is cool okay but
is that a is that a cancelable offense
that he said
a thing a bad word to a person who was
not black
in non-racist fashion that's not the
same thing as calling a black person the
n-word in any case he apologized for it
is that going to buy him any sort of
love of course not
by the way his neighbor who filmed this
thing and then put it online for the
laws
is a jackass and if you're sitting
around
being the stasi for the woke culture so
that you can just
tape people who are who are drunken
celebrities saying things that you don't
particularly like so you can get them
canceled
this makes you the bad person doesn't
mean what he said was appropriate
it does mean that you are not a you are
not any
arbiter of virtue if your entire life
revolves around taking out your phone
and taping people
doing things in drunken in drunken
states
seriously this is the culture that we
have become okay so morgan wallin issued
an apology he said the video you saw was
of me
on hour 72 of a bender that's not
something i'm proud of obviously the
natural thing is to apologize further
and just continue to apologize but
because you got caught
and that's not what i wanted to do and
he said he was aware that he had let
people down including his parents
and his son and then he explained that
he has accepted invitations from black
organizations executives and leaders to
have open and honest
conversations they offered me grace they
also paired that with an offer to learn
and to grow you think that's going to
work for morgan wallin apparently it
only works with people who are
of the left right if you're of the left
and you say anti-semitic or anti-white
like nick cannon still has his job
and nick cannon essentially suggested
that white people are monsters
and and he still is going to be having
his job at the end of the day
and iced tea has said wildly
anti-semitic stuff that dude's going to
have a job
so the the the sort of the
willingness to to allow people a second
chance again only extends to one side of
the aisle
not to the other side of the aisle
because presumably morgan wallin is
perceived as right-wing even if he is
not because he's a country singer
that is the way that things work
nowadays okay
this is not an argument that people
aren't saying things that are wrong it's
not an argument that unicron's original
post was great
it's not an argument that morgan wallin
should be using the n-word with his
friends none of that is true
the question is are these offenses that
should deprive people of their
livelihoods and careers
and the answer of course is no it's no
and if you're part of the culture that
suggests that people should lose their
livelihood in their career over this you
are part of the problem in the united
states and you're making the country
worse you're making the country much
worse you're not going to people quietly
and saying
in an effort to better the conversation
you know maybe you should take that down
because that's kind of inappropriate
or maybe that's a bad idea or maybe
that's overwrought instead you are
trying to ruin their lives
because they said something that you
disagree with this is not about
bettering the culture
it is not about making the country a
better place it is about you and your
under moral superiority because guess
what
i promise you i promise you that if
anybody spent half a moment
searching the social media feeds of the
bosses over at disney plus
or the lower downs over at the
mandalorian or any of the actors over at
the mandalorian they could come up with
stuff that's twice as bad as anything
carano's ever said
and if they searched all of the
recording industry executives
social media feeds and emails over the
past few years they can find stuff that
they've said that is significantly worse
and more damaging than anything morgan
wallin said that is the way our culture
works right now
none of this is about good faith making
the country a better place you know i
can tell because
every two weeks or so chris pratt trends
chris pratt trends on twitter
every two weeks or so not because he's
done anything or said anything every
time he trends i click on it
to see did they finally catch chris
pratt right
that's not what it is it's that people
are trending chris pratt because they
know that chris pratt is a christian
and because he is a christian they
suspect that he holds unpalatable social
issues views
and this means that if they can
preemptively cancel chris pratt they
will
i promise it's a real thing he trends
every couple of weeks on twitter
for no reason other than so they can say
that chris evans
he's kind of a jerk but that chris evans
is a wonderful wonderful human being
because he holds all the right left-wing
views and chris pratt is super bad
right chris pratt is the worst chris is
the way that they put it
why because of his social viewpoint
there is no honesty here
they would try to cancel chris pratt the
same today as they would tomorrow it's
just a question of whether there is a
hook that they can hang their hat on
they're trying to do the same thing to
tucker carlson today so tucker carlson
is once again trending on twitter
and all of the the boycotters are out
there trying to cudgel advertisers into
dropping his show
and they're trying to do so on the basis
of a monologue in which he discussed
george floyd
what he said in the monologue is that
died of a drug overdose now i don't know
whether george floyd died
drug overdose what i do know is that the
hennepin county medical examiner said
that he had enough fentanyl in a system
to kill a horse and if he had died in
his house
then rightly it would have been ascribed
to drug overdose now the hennepin county
medical examiner said i'm not saying
that the drug overdose killed him but he
did have an extraordinary level of
fentanyl in his system
so tucker essentially paraphrased the
medical
report from the hennepin county medical
examiner that happens to be the same
autopsy report the official autopsy
report being used by the defense
in the george floyd case so tucker cited
that
and now people are going nuts online
maybe advertisers should pull because
he's pushing a
conspiracy theory okay the autopsy is
not a conspiracy theory the autopsy is
an autopsy
you made us agree with that autopsy you
should find some medical evidence that
george floyd did not die of a medical
overdose
of some sort of some sort of drug
overdose and by the way that st
even if he died of a drug overdose that
still does not mean that the officer in
that particular case
would not have been guilty of use of
excessive force right that's also a
possibility
i've said that since the beginning if
you're going to go for a conviction in
the george floyd case
rather than grandstanding the easy
conviction is probably excessive force
not murder okay because it's hard to
prove causation in terms of murder when
the person is
suffering from what is pretty clearly
excited delirium begs to be pushed out
of the car by the cops refuses to sit
down
they treat him decently for a while and
then finally
when when the his knee his neck is knelt
upon for eight minutes which is a
terrible video
when that happens it turns out that he
doesn't have any damage to his trachea
for example
like there's there are certain realities
of medical science that
are going to be taken into account
during the trial so you can say
excessive force without having said
murder but
beyond that do you deserve to have
advertisers boycott you
because you cited a medical report in a
contentious trial
is that the way this works now here's
the deal they don't care what tucker
says on a daily basis
they don't care what i say on a daily
basis and they don't care what you say
on a daily basis
if they know what you believe they're
just waiting and all that is happening
right now is they are just waiting
they're waiting for the mouse trap to
snap on you and snap your neck
politically speaking that is all they
are waiting for it is not about an
honest attempt to cleanse the culture
it is not about an honest attempt to
have a discussion or a conversation it
is about
can we wrongfoot you so that we have an
excuse to say that your entire career
has been completely and utterly uh
garbage
and that you are a bad person and so we
feel good in excising you from the body
politic and twilight zone wishing you
out into the cornfield
that's all that's happening right now in
the culture and that is a big deal it is
a big deal to you it is a big deal to me
it should be a big deal to your company
it should be a big deal to your friends
that's the pressure that so many people
are feeling by the way
right left hand center liberals feel
this way there's a reason 150 liberals
wrote a letter to harper's weekly
decrying this sort of stuff
this is not a right left issue this is a
left versus everybody else issue this is
a hard left versus everybody else issue
and the hard left is in control
and we are going to have to consolidate
and fight back against it because it
really is garbage it is garbage
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content